[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
non
premières impressions
c'est en matière de lutte anti cette
politique anti 3
ici les hommes toujours été tributaire
de l'élevage de père en fils
les paysans se transmettent leur
savoir-faire et l'amour de la terre mais
cet équilibre est menacée les
transformations accélérées et anarchique
de l'économie impose trop souvent aux
agriculteurs de nouvelles contraintes en
1968 la france est déstabilisé le monde
agricole traverse une nouvelle crise et
c'est dans ce contexte que jean chapeau
réalise un documentaire sur une famille
de paysans léfèvre
[Musique]
c'est lui qui m'a donné l'idée de ce
film lui et les siens
c'est une grande famille paysanne du
haut doubs
il habite à côté de pontarlier tout près
de la frontière suisse
je les ai connus quand je suis entré
dans cette société patriarcale
j'ai senti quelque chose de très
précieux que j'ai eu peur de voir mourir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui plus de 30 ans se sont
écoulés ce quelque chose de très
précieux qui est peut être la paysanne
me semble toujours en péril
à travers les portraits des fils febre
jean chapeau annoncé les grands
changements que l'agriculture est les
subir pour s'adapter au monde moderne
et c'est à ces portraits que je me suis
attaché
robert l'un des fils ils étaient
partisans de l'élan moderniste des
années 60 mais il a été confronté aux
contradictions de la politique agricole
mis en place à cette époque pour ludique
pour améliorer le revenu des
agriculteurs
il faudrait qu'il y ait un certain
nombre qui partent qu'ils quittent la
terre qu'ils sont trop nombreux et bien
je peux vous affirmer que pour notre
région
c'est faux mais un mètre carré de terre
de mon exploitation mais il comptait il
dit pour moi ça c'est corps avec moi
aussi j'étais erreur avoir acheté un
champ j'étais heureux elle a jamais su
ce que c'était que des compliments spoil
l'aîné de la famille a épousé gaby
millions au fait ou fait comme si on
était propriétaire question de leurs
modes d'exploitation et leur choix dit
s'opposer au productivisme et dominant
celui qui peut pas la faire qu'ils
veulent c'est moi j'ai aidé un truc
que j'étais révolutionnaire la terre a
subi à traiter ce thème était prêt sous
la pression des propriétaires
aujourd'hui peu les morts gaby est
finalement devenu propriétaire de cette
petite ferme
elle exploite avec son fils bernard
toute façon aux missions ne serait pas
se retrouver à la rue
allait on trouve un appartement quelque
chose donc je n'avais pas fait moins
chaud
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait des enfants
et puis j'ai acheté la maison et puis je
suis parti dans le métier donné 1400
être prêtre ou instituteur
c'était le seul choix qui s'offrait à
pierre le plus jeune des fils moi
j'aurais aimé y être paysan voulait
faire on a ça dans le sang
mais j'étais le seul de la famille à
être allés à lui en ai ans qu'on se fait
mal que quelqu'un d'instruit de tommy
disait parce que tu es lisant
amoureux de la nature pierre a toujours
porté sur le monde rural un regard
généreux étant empreint de nostalgie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pierre a enfin réalisé son
rêve être paysan il est à la retraite et
cela lui permet lité de montée à
l'alpage pour des propriétaires suisses
parfois le dimanche ses frères jean et
rené viennent voir comment passez un hit
routot par là un couteau dans sa poche
l'allemande a hébergé depuis 14 ans je
fais le berger et bars je sais que c'est
beaucoup plus facile de s'occuper des
bêtes que de s'occuper des gamins des
gambier et et hôteliers restaurateurs
est beaucoup plus de travail que dans la
culture
[Musique]
en 1968 ont présenté le tourisme comme
alternative à l'agriculture
[Musique]
je ne faisais rien de rester et
cultivateurs mais ça ne m'a rien fait
quitter nous peut vous je me plais bien
dans ce métier-là rni a quitté la ferme
familiale il a épousé une fille dotée
levier avec elle à nouveau métier qui a
assuré leur avenir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui rené a passé le relais à son
fils
marc a beaucoup voyagé pour se
perfectionner dans son métier est de
retour au pays il a pu faire prospérer
le restaurant familial
le tourisme est devenu une valeur sûre
[Rires]
j'ai trois bâtiments à tenir qui ne sont
pas un modèle bâti mauritus alors et
enfin genre c'est le dernier des fils
faivre à s'être mariée c'est pour ça
qu'il a dû rester à la ferme familiale
les granges tavernier
il a d'abord été l'employé de ses
parents puis il est devenu à son tour
propriétaire aujourd'hui grâce à jean
les granges tavernier continue à vivre
il y habite en famille avec l'aîné de
ses fils michel et son petit fils
vincent aura vous moquez pas dit qu'on
nous déloge il y en a qui ne vont pas au
comice pas du tout mais bon bah on aime
ou n'aime pas sa peine fierté
attends j'ai un animal rouge comme celui
là il ya beaucoup plus de chances que
oui impliqué tout ça ils fuient ces
retouches aux jeunes ont à s'occuper de
chaque que des retraités est ce que vous
êtes retraité de pi oblige en disant je
vais avoir 75 alors passé l'organisation
c'est à dire que avant la retraite quand
il ya eu l'âge on s'est mis au gaec
peyrefiche puis quand j'ai pris ma
retraite est tellement fort il a
continué seul est-ce que vous avez deux
fils louis oui justement j'avais tenu un
petit peu plus longtemps parce que le
deuxième fiche était à l'armée puis dit
quand il va rentrer il va reprendre ma
place
nicolas puis l'a préférée oui de toute
façon il n'y avait pas assez pour deux
jeunes ménages question de quotas
laitiers question de
et puis il était à ces paysans alors
hilaire concerne
[Musique]
mais pas la longue et pinceaux lorgnette
ses lames hp gamins à l'école mais les
plus anciennes que je connais encore les
noms comme elle s'appelle m'en faire et
nour
je me rappelle - déjà on oublie
la boulangère de taille avec la plus
ancienne section vous ressortir
s'amusant l'un d'eux puisse m'en dans
quatre ans
parce que
je pense que
mon rêve ça avait triché
[Musique]
robert travaille très dur il a décidé
lui de réussir d'être un paysan moderne
qui a des pompes et des budgets des
bilans plus et amortissements
et très vite le progrès parce qu'après
la guerre et il fait un petit peu là pas
la famine mais ont manqué de beaucoup
beaucoup de produits
on a incité les gens à produire toujours
plus puis mon dieu avec l'inflation
parce que l'inflation était quand même
nous aider quand même bien qu'ils
disaient on emprunter pour acheter une
vache pour la rembourser un christ ou
dans la paix avec le bétail dans les
performances et tous était paraît il
contre lecce mettre le bazar quoi il a
fait ce qu'il fallait il fallait
toujours progresser toujours toujours on
a été dépassés tout en essayant de bien
faire on a été déclassé drôlement
dépassé moi j'étais même les dernières
années juge je ne suivait plus pas pu
suivre
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle race de paysans se lève
dans le haut doubs l'airé culture de ce
pays survie ce sera grâce à robert et à
d'autres jeunes comme lui j'ai toujours
eu envie de faire une grosse et une
exploitation
chaque fois que j'ai pu chercher des
terres ou bien genre loi côté que bon
chaque fois que je pouvais et puis je
faisais tout pour enfants pour qu'ils
aient une continuation
j'aurais été vraiment déçu si mon garçon
le seul que j'avais était parti
travailler ailleurs
je sais peut-être c'était tout le monde
mon espoir non mon bonheur d'être avec
lui comme dit mon fort l'accident à tous
c'est comme si le ciel m'était tombé sur
la tête quoi
je
on était nombreux en famille on était
huit à tous nos parents n'ont pas fait
le fermier y en a combien trois coques
voyons quand même 5 5 les huit la
génération prêt et bien une ens et un
fils qui a repris ici
alors finalement il restait plus que
deux des six placer de ma génération et
de vous les 2 me +12 l'aîné de mes
frères c'est un bon paysan méticuleux
qu'il faisait bien son travail de la
moitié de son bouquet de la communion sa
petite fille qui n'a pas connu
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis sa photo la
habitude elle est là bas devant
l'ampleur n'a pas connu ses
petits-enfants dakar a écouté les
parties le décalage les 70 dollars à son
papa est mort il avait 20 ème jour de
ses 24 ans un anniversaire le m
bernard le fils de paul et gaby est
l'héritier d'un mode d'agriculture des
gens marge l'époque
aujourd'hui il est de ceux qui
résistaient la mondialisation et c'est
tout naturellement qu'il s'est orienté
vers l'agriculture biologique
[Musique]
agriculteurs un peu par accident ou le
décès de mon père et puis bon c'est un
peu un coup du sort son nom vient des
piges mehdi peut-être qu'il va y avoir
quelque chose qui va se présenter à vous
et qui va me ferait rire orienté changer
très près de 400 professionnels
j'en passe et austère n'existe de moto
et puis parce que ma mère 76 ans et plus
[Musique]
trop sage et souffle un petit cours à sa
passion sa passion que le temps
n'était pas pour être avec puissiez bien
mais ce que bien tomber taille ça qui me
dit ça il serait mieux tout seul
[Musique]
michel est le fils aîné de jean c'est
lui qui exploite maintenant le domaine
des granges tavernier propriétaires de
ces terres il s'agrandit se modernisent
pour maintenir une exploitation
performante et rentable
son fils vincent âgé de 13 ans l'aide à
la ferme
[Musique]
et vienne
allez allez vas toi aller
[Applaudissements]
ouais
voilà le lait l'élevage ce sont les
seuls moyens de vivre du paysan tué ce
matin et soir tous les jours il faut
porter le lait à la fromagerie au chalet
comme on dit ici chaque village a son
petit chalet on y transforme le lait en
compte et et si le fromage se vend mal
c'est la faillite car ici en montagne à
1000 mètres
on ne peut faire comme les mages rien
d'autre l'oreillette en 238 jours à la
fait 5000 litres de lait a fait 43e de
thé b 34,6 de tp c'est quoi comme au
tennis et au but éric et et pis c'est
tout protéique
je suis en troisième enfin j'aimerais
aller à dannemarie états unis comme des
tripes ils te pour après qu'on appelait
[Musique]
nicolas le second fils de jean et
locataires d'une exploitation de taille
moyenne chaque été ils montrent ces
jeunes bêtes à l'alpage ce qui lui
permet de réserver les prix autour de la
ferme pour ses vaches laitières
nicolas et sa femme caroline souhaitent
devenir propriétaires et agrandir leur
exploitation de bien
comment
des passages quotidiens au rabais les
vtt avant quand les tories
ben ali vers juste en location comme
chauffeurs de dameuses par les pistes je
les airs sur la neige
maintenant je les fais à pied on allait
les choix ici on préfère très du lait
que de faire autre chose que par choix
ou besoin déjà ceux qui font des fermes
auberges ou d'égypte des gîtes c'est
plus par besoin que que autre chose sur
la nécessité parce que soit il n'y a pas
assez gros des revenus sur
l'exploitation avec avec le lait ou
alors oui il ya une personne en plus à
la maison pic convient de se caser sur
pasqua quand ils trouvent un boulot sur
pf
quand on a 60 hectares on a un nombre de
vaches qui va avec on peut pas on peut
pas en avoir plus d'audace on veut bien
l ailier ou au terrain déjà on fait la
moyenne de l'exploitation par exemple
mauger 180 mille litres de lait par an a
produit / par 60 hectares ce qui nous
donne
comment le nombre de litres de lait par
hector cocon produit quoi sur
l'exploitation chez sal moi j'aurais qu
une vingtaine de milles litres en plus
bon ça permettrait way a été de
continuellement sur la ferme quoi avec
la carole quoi on pourrait vivre les
dessus sans problème quoi la ferme la
ferme sans les primes avec les prix
qu'on l'a aujourd'hui elle vit mais on
nous pour nous n'aurez pas de salaire
quoi ça c'est grave
oui oui c'est quand même assez grands
par rapport à l'europe par rapport à
toute cette pression
parce que les prix arrive au même niveau
et puis c'est prévu compense pas dit
avec mu est payé de son produit que
quelques boucheries
à
[Musique]
oh
ça
[Musique]
mais bon la laiterie mais c'est bien
assez grand
8h05 complété par plaques est de 5 par 5
pieds alors celui là tu le plant ici
contre le club qui n'en est pas là
l'autre étoile a montré tous là en gros
avec notre système interviendrait à 35
mille francs baroeul ceci ici on fait
tout faire on a dit à la banque mais bon
la banque elle a dit que c'était
possible mais c'est qu'après oui on veut
enfin établi un dossier
et puis il fait il parlera les passages
dédiés à 10 passes lasers et puis à la
cdo
alors ça peut être avoir refusé d'ici là
la bouilloire remboursement fait objet
se serrer la ceinture quand elle bien
perdre des kilos
enfin moi pas tout oui bon je dis
toujours ça va aller elle tourne pas oui
ça va aller pays nous injurient
ou pas les racheter du matériel tour
nécessité un investissement assez
important alors nous avons modernisé par
la force des choses il ya eu un peu
d'auto financement mais autrement nous
avions crédit agricole nous avons fait
pas mal d'emprunt bien sûr ce n'est pas
très folichon poussée entre eux et j'ai
toujours assez lourd
vous savez les agriculteurs rien n'a pas
notre point qu'il mettait de l'argent de
côté et incite au contraire il fallait y
avait toujours à rembourser il a
toujours le crédit agricole prennent
enfin il fallait pas oublier d'en
pousser les jeunes agriculteurs ont foi
en leur métier ils aiment leur métier et
il voudrait bien pouvoir en vivre mais
sans être des assistés
on les oblige à tellement
d'investissement aujourd'hui ils ne sont
plus maîtres de leur affaire ils sont
pris dans une espèce de mécanique
ils sont obligés avant de commencer
d'investir d'emprunter et d'y aller
n'ont pas le choix je pense que pour
finir on va presque fonctionnaires parce
que ça continue on sera en sera
heureusement ça sera l'état qui va
suivre ça continue a pas ce qu'on me
donne des primes pour faire ceci et puis
vous faire cela nous oblige les trucs
alors que ouais ça se passe c'est pas
vraiment ce qui nous intéresse mais cela
dit culte de maintenance était en fête
qui te fait vivre série primée mais
c'est pour dire qu'on soit wars forts
que sont le bien comme ça mais tu peux
pas faire autrement que de toute façon
[Musique]
seul investi de nouveaux joueurs soit
j'arrête que je pourrai obligé d'arrêter
l'exploitation
parce que oui à l'énorme secousse hiver
lors des normes au niveau de
l'assainissement au niveau des fosses à
purin niveau donc automatiquement je
serais obligé d'investir je reste
agriculteurs pour moi vieux c'est
revenir à une agriculture traditionnelle
voilà ma main je pense qu'elle m'a elle
m'a pas pousser mais elle était contre
cette agriculture attend c'est là que
l'on travaillé mais ce qui m'intéressait
aussi c'est elle le fait qu'ils sont
contre la transplantation embryonnaire
ou donc toutes les manipulations
génétiques ça je n'ai jamais fait puis
non je trouve ça complètement optionné
donc la possibilité de dans une même
étape d'abord pratiquement dix ou quinze
vaches issus de la même mère parce que
là on nous fait croire que ça va être un
progrès alors que tout le monde sait
très bien que c'est un risque au niveau
sanitaire au niveau
et puis se perdent un peu d'identité de
chaque animal quoi de claudie ouais mais
ça veut pas revenir en arrière n'est pas
possible
moi j'aime autant avoir fait mon temps
d'être obligée à le faire
regardez mon changement juste les
dessins en train de prendre un nouveau
virage où les gens sont aperçu qu'on
pouvait pas faire n'importe quoi en
agriculture et puis qu'il fallait
revenir peut-être des choses le plus
traditionnel
donc le respect des animaux respect de
l'environnement c'est pour ça que je
suis militant la confédération paysanne
les syndicats majoritaires a été ça et
plus pour une agriculture intensive et
prenait justement l'augmentation des
cotations alors que la confédération
cherche plutôt à limiter la reprise des
terres
aujourd'hui ça bouge un peu mais c'est
un petit peu les parents pauvres n'en
sais pas les gros souliers de son
passage
c'est à dire sur le deuxième le deuxième
syndicat
c'est un petit peu le syndicat des
pauvres voire disons oui voilà oui les
gros céréaliers ne sont pas là dedans 1
mais là les petits agriculteurs n'a pas
menti
ils sont maintenant maintenant ça se
développe
aurait on fait partir il faut déjà bien
que moi je la laisse traîner partout
[Musique]
à
oui j'en prends ça veut dire quoi ce
prix pourrait aller
m
[Musique]
j'ai assuré démentant du var et des
alpes maritimes où la vigilance orange a
été sur ma table
rafale ne sont beaucoup moins violentes
que cette nuit sur la corse la vigilance
orange est en convaincu
m
[Musique]
j'avais quelque chose à déclarer pas de
marchandises ça va bien merci et au
revoir monsieur assez
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas la maison on avait des
lapins on avait des cochons il n'avait
été une époque pendant la guerre surtout
na des moutons pour avoir de la laine
quand vous avez vous à filer la laine
généralement tous ces petits bestiaux
comme ça c'était les femmes qui sont
occupés et puis à l'époque les femmes
n'y a plus guère quillan la maison de
mon travail ailleurs alors à nous plutôt
de s'occuper de cette fois on vivait
encore bien de nos produits
c'est là que les gens pour arriver à
s'en tirer quoi
silencieux
c'est celle de gens les plus d'efforts
mais celle de rené en tout cas elles
n'ont pas trop de corne
si tu tiens manque de poubelles ne porte
pas ses fruits et des légumes verts ce à
n'importe qui celui là mais pas imaginer
pouces qui se retourne toi allez lui en
effet prince et quand il doit surtout
sur ses ambitions amoureux un principe a
enfin c'est ce que j'ai toujours entendu
dire moi les miens ils vont dans notre
sens et de veut dire quoi mon frère
pierre est méritée reze loire j'ai
montré enfin je pense il me faut mais je
ne m'attache femmes enfants
[Musique]
au brésil est le côté cette envergure
ont eu du flair tendre mon avenir là son
concept opération terminée
patience et longueur de sport confie je
passe outre les gaillacois la rue de la
porte
c'est vrai la montbéliard où j'ai pas
fichés parce qu'on y habitue mais où est
sa plus beau que les bêtes en pâture
c'est toujours beau petit rond comme
takamba noir qu'elle soit route elle
pois blancs
[Musique]
normalement il devrait s'enfoncer keaton
je comprends pas que ses paroles
aujourd'hui que la pluie qui a eu une
grosse journée boules de foin chez tous
sont tous fous ont fauché hier à redire
il faut six projets ramasse occupe pas
ses plus beaux succès tron
trop poussé
quand lui tendit ville sont complètement
il faut faire tout dans quinze jours
alors qu'on mettait deux mois par les
bois entièrement il s'était fait tout
était fait par tous
[Musique]
aujourd'hui où elle n'est pas trop
pressé parce que bon ça menace pas leur
âge mais
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
non
voir
[Musique]
maintenant c'est vrai un peu mieux en
frontal quatre ans lançons ce soir c'est
comme quand on va faire le bâtiment ça
ne nous fait pas même encore pas mon but
quand même le faire mais c'est vrai
qu'au début quand même plus à trouver
que vous mais moi j'ai toujours dit
qu'une paix double nom apparaisse quoi
puis c'est quand même des
investissements d'une entreprise pas de
oui c'est une entreprise quand même une
chute tout ça c'est la même chose et pas
autrement non moins votre fierté d'avoir
notre truc à nous qu'on qui marche bien
voilà nous tout ça c'est les vaches
avant nous mais parce que nous on en a
rien à je fais quoi d'une salle à
manger d'avoir à manger dans l'assiette
et ses salles de bain puis après ils
s'en foutent
[Musique]
mais les affinités la polaire de couple
mais je t'ai déjà dit qu'il fallait
compenser une fois un univers et de
passer un hiver on our à jarlard et la
ja la fenêtre de grenier qui on se fait
un lièvre à noël ou nouvel an plus tôt
on installe les shows on va mettre des
chemins sur le balcon un lièvre bien
qu'aussi bien je renvoie on y fera quand
même la faire comprendre bien est-ce
qu'on visait au départ il a aussi dit la
vérité
au fait vous êtes au courant il paraît
que
faire des gaillards ne m'en parle de
jeunes abonde comment ça se fait et
comme pour tout bon il ne veut pas
failli et apparemment il ya beaucoup de
bêtes
ouais il a pas beaucoup de bêtes pour
remplir davantage donc il doit trouver
dès lors que les tiennes a su surmonter
à d autres indiens personne ne semble
savoir faire quoi après dakar où l'eau
souillée comme il est à présent de ne
plus être obligé de rentrer sans payer
les soins divers sites le maire de
teuhpu que sa douce adieu patrick hansen
[Musique]
il ya même fait de la culture puis de
brûler à côté je vois que c'est pas
mieux fait pas mieux chez les suisses
[Musique]
tous les agriculteurs suisses qui sont
contre l'entrée dans la communauté les
cultures non mais on aborde un petit 5 %
de la population donc hériter
d'agriculteurs non avec attendait quand
on est bientôt pour vous oui je ne vous
donne pas attendre oulala rôle à moi je
sais que enfin il faut pas faire c'est
s'ils savaient que politique comme ça
mais un bon chez soi non on n'a pas été
mélangés avec les autres mais non mais
non mais faut reconnaître que si un jour
vous entrez dans la communauté
européenne
que vous soyez obligé d'aligner gaumont
pris à ceux de la communauté européenne
le paysan suisse on croyait que ou pas
vienne à d autres des plus pour que les
français non mais aussi comment les
aligner quand voir arriver les polonais
aussi ça nous a bien sûr sa voracité pas
seulement pour l'agriculture tout le
monde rêve le croque la vie culture
saqqaq penseront qu'à paris c'est tout
[Musique]
malgré une proposition de ceux qui
souhaitaient poursuivre des armements de
l'irak en la voie pacifique sans
associer pleinement leurs alliés
européens dans cette première version
lite est plutôt étonnant la réunion
demain de permettre aux moyens
d'afficher la même ambition pour
l'europe que celle exprimée ce matin par
le président de la république
j'ai été contre mot strict fort pour des
raisons un peu personnel quoi mais moi
je trouve que ça ne peut pas se faire
autrement
qu'est-ce qu'elle ferait la france tout
seul volet chat chirac aurait bourdier
ça n'a pas de sens
un grain de sable dans le désert c'est
c'est une obligation dans l'avenir quand
on pense aux états unis le pouvoir qui
se disent qu'ils ont acquis en étant
tous ensemble et la force qui représente
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
s'il n'y a pas un contrepoids passe les
gens là mais feront nous des esclaves
bon ou est ce qu'on n'est pas oulala ça
sent bon rouge un petit reste en dessous
ça vous la nation ou pas oh
continuera mais y en avoir des
agriculteurs n'est de moins en moins
parce qu'ils vont ils exploitent de plus
en plus grand avec des moyens appropriés
et avec moi d'amour peut-être moins de
patients ben forcément ils sont moins
attachés notaire à nous la la terre nous
coller à tout pour que dallas mais oui
une parcelle de terre c'est sacré rêvons
long
homogène
m
tous
[Musique]
joe nicolas pas pris du volume
parmi les nombreux descendants de marque
faible 3 seulement sont restés paysans
michel bernard et nicolas sont restés
très attachés à leur terre et à leurs
bétails et c'est peut-être cela qui leur
permet de résister encore aux
contraintes économiques la
mondialisation menace leur autonomie de
gestion
pourtant avec eux j'ai senti que ce lien
essentiel ce quelque chose de très
précieux dont nous parlait déjà jean
chapeau ne veut pas mourir et ne doit
pas mourir avant vous passerez par les
branches de vernoux entre chez les faire
parler avec eux ils sont très
accueillants
[Musique]